i
had such a great time watching this it's
it's just such a
engrossing story once you get into it
and
good i'm curious i mean when this came
your way how much did you get to know
about that
did you get somewhat of a sense of what
this full story would be or did you not
have much to go on
well i they they gave me the first four
episodes in script form and i read them
i knew i wanted to be a part of it
because i couldn't get up
when i was reading them i i didn't get
up until i read all four
and um i wanted to find out what
happened next so i was like okay this is
a good sign if it's this good on paper
you know it's going to be good when
after we shoot it um and
i think i knew up until like at least
episode 7 and then they were kind of
writing as they were going on so
we were surprised as well this is
something that
has it creates a whole world to it and
it also has
all of these really interesting
characters that inhabit it
so was it one thing versus the other
that
really sort of most drew you to it as
far as was it the world versus the
characters or was it both things
it was definitely both things um i knew
um
i was drawn to the world i love the idea
of this investigative journalist
um world travel just you know
sophisticated
you know layered woman who's kind of
feeling stagnation in her life and
and wants to be passionate again about
life and
in comes this story that she has to help
crack
um and uh
i love the you know the show runners and
uh
you know don and nicole and i love the
fact that it was
an international story that
you know we were bringing together um
tel aviv
and new york these two great cities so
much about it
i loved are you i love it i got to shoot
in new york in the fall
yeah that must have been beautiful
yeah it was nice are you someone who
likes to get
involved as far as you know establishing
a relationship
with the showrunners and having a say
in your character or do you sort of just
hand over the trust to them once you
start shooting
i you know one of the the things i loved
about collaborating with don and nicole
is that you know we had i
they had ideas about naomi but they were
definitely very open to
input and it kind of i kind of helped
come up with the back story with them
and um i always find that that's
a more satisfying experience when you
can if a character is being created if
you can help create that
so definitely is it refreshing to play
someone that seems to know who she is
and makes no apologies or excuses for
who she is
yeah it is it yeah it's definitely
um i have a lot of respect for naomi i
don't know that i would uh
put myself in the situation she puts it
herself in but it's all for the truth
and justice
finding that she's a seeker of truth and
justice and
she's going to do whatever it takes to
get that
you've previously talked about how the
process of acting is similar in approach
to investigative reporting
was that something that you'd realized
or ever thought about
prior to playing this character or did
delving into her world help you see
those similarities
definitely delving into her world
talking to people
talking to investigative journalists um
it i was like oh yeah this is you know
each story is kind of like
a different character the way that i
approach acting is
is really a holistic holistic kind of
process it's
lots of research and for me it's like
really kind of investigating
investigating the whole world
of where that actor where that character
comes from and so yeah there are a lot
of similarities
at the point in the story that we meet
her it seems as though she feels a bit
stuck with her work and unable to
progress in a way that
she'd like to be able to so
you know learning about this story that
sort of falls in her lap
what do you think it is about the spark
and the chase of a good story that
really gets her going and that really
sort of
makes her feel like she's found that
again he's alive right
i think that it's it's like any it's
it's addictive for her i think that um
it's like
putting a puzzle together for you know a
puzzle aficionado it's
it's it's like once she starts
she can't and she gets hooked she can't
stop until she solves it
and so she is feeling stuck in her life
and her going on this journey
um makes her feel alive again
i love the weird energy between naomi
and her husband
and and sega and ron
and the weird moments between the four
of them
what were those scenes like to play and
explore what was the atmosphere
on set like for those scenes they're fun
it was really fun everybody is a great
sport
and even though there was a lot of
tension
in the show and intrigue
it was a pretty uh friendly light set
lots of laughter
sometimes too much laughter i was like
okay let's let this focus now
but it was cool it was fun what did you
most enjoy about exploring that
relationship between naomi
and sega because it's such a complicated
and complex relationship and i don't
think we get to see
relationships like that very often yeah
i mean
you know i'm friends with a bunch of my
exes
um i feel like it is a it's it's a
different kind of relationship one
because she's married but also because
you know it's like you had a history so
there's
it's more than friends but it still has
to be platonic because
you're you're no longer together and i
just find that
interesting it's interesting to watch
and
interesting to play and you feel that
coming across
with with the relationship between segev
and naomi
it was so great to see you in the
trailer for season three of succession
i'm excited the show is coming back and
i'm excited that you've joined the show
and it's interesting because over the
last year i've asked a lot of actors
what tv show they'd want to guest on
and 99.9 percent of them
say that it would be successful oh
that's great
what's it like to actually join the show
it was great um i honestly i had never
seen succession when i got the offer
and um so i had to binge it
and it was the funnest research i had
ever done i was like oh god this is so
great
um it's such good writing such
good actors i had
a blast i had a blast working on it
what can you say about nothing
i can't say anything except
you're it's going to be more of what
everybody loves about it
you know this this crazy
roy family and you know how their drama
unfolds will be just as
compelling as we've been used to
is it intimidating to join a show in a
cast like that
or is it just fun to get to play with
such
great material you know honestly i've
been doing it so long and i've
i've done it on different shows so now
it's um
it's definitely i always get nervous
when i start a new job
but it it was it's
more excitement than than nerves and
they were a great group of people so
welcoming and
and um just consummate professionals so
i had a good experience
how did your experience compare when you
did something like
joining the affairs so late in its run
what did
what was that like what did what did you
learn from doing that show
well it's similar i was a with the
affair i had been watching it i was
a fan of it from the beginning and i
just you know i really
thought that it was some of the best
writing on tv best acting and
for me it was just kind of like cool i
get to come
and play with these
um actors who i felt uh i really
respected
and it was similar in that respect
in that you know i'm joining a cast
that's already
kind of together so you know yeah you do
feel like the the new kid
you know the first the new kid at school
at first but you get used to it
your episode of the twilight zone was
arguably one of the best from the jordan
peel revival
in parliament thank you yeah i mean i
thought it was such a great episode
and part of that was because it really
very directly took on race
do you feel like those sorts of stories
are better served when they're very
direct about the issues being discussed
um well i loved that i loved i really
was so excited
to be a part of that particular episode
because
it really it it wasn't direct and it was
such a creative way
to get into the mind of a black mother
and
what black mothers in this society have
dealt with
for hundreds and hundreds of years and
still unfortunately have to deal with
day after day after day and
it's kind of to me um
in a weird way more impactful to an
audience because if you're seeing it on
the news every day you can get
a little numb and you can get a little
desensitized so
um the way in the creepy eerie
way into that that black mother's mind
and and seeing her you know having to
relive
this experience over and over again i
think gives a different
perspective and understanding and you
know
for that reality it's still the episode
that stands out
to me that i think of when i think about
that series i love it thank you 11
basketball came out more than 20 years
ago now and that's a movie that people
still love and will likely always love
what
impact did love basketball make on you
and your life
and how do you view its legacy just in
film in general
well i had um i really
it was my first starring
role in a movie and um i fought for it i
had to audition
for five months it was grueling i
learned a lot about myself
during that you know audition process
almost quit didn't quit i think back on
like wow what if i did what if i quit
you know
um and for me
you know when we were shooting i had
come from the theater so i'd been
doing lots of acting and and
was confident in in that area
and yet i had i so i approached it
like i had approached every role and so
when you're on the set
you're just going through the days i
remember shooting it and it was just
over and i was like hope it's good
you just never know and then i remember
sitting
at sundance we had a premiere at
sundance and then we got like a
five-minute
standing ovation after and i was like
wow
that's when it hit me this really
it really worked the script that i read
script that i was fighting for that i
was so in love with
you know we we did it justice so
for me that was you know everything
and um the fact that people are still
coming up to me every day tweeting at me
every day talking about how they still
watch it
is just like icing on the cake
one of the things i i really love about
hit and run is that
you know typically these are very male
stories and the female characters
are there to serve some purpose for the
male protagonist
yeah i love that this character is not
like that was that something that was
also really important to you that she
have a very full story that she have
this life
absolutely i mean you want to play you
know
three-dimensional characters you don't
want to be accessories
or you know just plot points that move
the story
forward um that's important to me in
choosing my characters and i love that
she was going through her own
um her own struggles and
and obstacles even in addition to
her obstacles of cracking this story and
that even though you know
maybe her husband wasn't happy with it
she still made the decision to go
forward
with it you know um
yeah i'm from los angeles and i love it
when a movie or
tv show captures los angeles in a way
that you're not used to seeing and i
feel like this really does that
with new york what do you like about the
way that new york is portrayed in us
well first of all i was just so thrilled
that we were actually shooting in new
york there's so many
movies that shoot new york and you're
not shooting in new york
um so being this was pre-pandemic and
and um it was new york city in the fall
so that in and of itself was so
attractive to me
like i get to shoot in in new york city
in the fall
um i thoroughly enjoyed it
lots of um location scenes we were shot
in brooklyn in queens
you know one day we shot in the middle
of times square
new york is really a character in it as
well as tel aviv
unfortunately i didn't get to go to tel
aviv but um i was like can i go
um but you'll see
that you know this is really a true
international story and i love seeing
how culturally these two cultures are
portrayed
in the in the story and it makes it so
worldly
well thank you for talking about it i
really dug it so
thank you christina thank you thank you